middle child two brothers were actually
very close but they lived in different
states only child childhood obsessions
Christmas magic
my name is Michael you're a great dancer
you're a terrible liar and that's kid
I've always imagined that my life was
like a typical romantic comedy you were
so confident and you just swooped off
your clothes like you're strippered a
bachelorette party and I basically
shower with clothes on
don't just shut up now shall we go to
your place tonight here's my door before
we go in just open the door okay
what is this Michael oh you don't want
to oh my God they're in here too
I think you're very cool and I'm worried
that you're going to break my heart you
know that this is my friend Mike a
friend yes Mom just a friend what is
going on here who is this guy he's my
boyfriend your boyfriend I think it's a
great kid we may not look like it but we
are actually kind of hip oh my God we
were gonna go to Woodstock you know
well I am let's just take a moment to
appreciate this beauty
what is going on are you all right come
down off the ledge Mike I'm seeing a
doctor tomorrow
I'm afraid the news isn't good
I was always afraid kit would break my
heart and eventually he did he broke it
open I've only got one
you have to run the race in front of you
because that's all there is
look back this is less of a rom-com and
more of the love story you can't sit for
four hours we promised all the beds are
occupied get my husband a bed well that
was Oscar worthy worked for Shirley
MacLaine
sorry I never told you how good your ass
looks in your khaki pants I was afraid
if you understood how beautiful you are
that you'd leave me thank you for
inviting us and it was Kiss idea I was
vehemently opposed to it
and like all love stories it never
actually ends